hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
developing flow-based analytical methods
for gene-edited
car t programs how to ensure an
efficient transition from early research
to clinical development
i am jennifer woods of labrutz and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by miltoni biotek
to learn more visit miltonybiotic.com
let's get started before we begin i'd
like to remind everyone that this event
is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions
as you want at any time you want during
the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation click on the support
tab found at the top right of the
presentation window
or report your problem by clicking on
the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab
located at the top right of the
presentation window
and follow the process to obtain your
credits
i now present today's speaker erin
edwards
scientist car t in vitro biology lead
beam therapeutics for a complete
biography on our speaker please visit
the biography tab at the top of your
screen
erin you may now begin your presentation
thank you thanks for having me i'm going
to start today's talk
uh with an agenda of what i'll be
speaking about today
uh first i'm going to start a review of
car t biology the generations of car t
products uh a reminder for those uh not
as familiar with the stages of drug
development
we'll then discuss some key reminders
when you're building out
cartoon analytics infrastructures five
areas to really ensure
an optimal transition of those
facts-based analytics that you've
created
from research to clinical development
some areas for potential loss of
data continuity and solutions and then
how
we at bean therapeutics have integrated
miltoni biotech's infrastructure into
our workflows
from early research through clinical
development
car t for those that aren't familiar is
stands for
chimeric antigen receptor t cells
which are a chimera of t cell receptors
which
you can see in the figure and the scfv
region from an antibody
that can be engineered into a t cell
with specificity
towards a cancer antigen or other
antigen depending on the
area of interest that you're focused on
while car t cells are already complex
products
due to their the nature of them being a
cell therapy
each generation of successive car t
products is becoming even more complex
over time
with the integration of multiple
signaling receptors
gene editing technology and synthetic
biology
that is also requiring analytics to
keep up with its complexity over time
these anal these analytical assays also
evolve and change many times throughout
a product's development cycle
i'm showing a figure here with the
trajectory
from early research groups or
development stages all the way through
commercial life commercialization of
your product
and with these analytical assays being
developed by the time you get to
commercial you might see
something along the lines of the seventh
version of such analytical assay being
developed
where in the early stages of research
you then transition the first version of
that assay to the next stage
receive feedback fine-tune improve
and so on over time
with the goal in mind to keep efficient
transitions
of these analytical assays throughout
each phase of development
but also speed up the time from a
concept
in the early research stage to
commercial it's really important to
minimize the changes made over assays
so that you can have efficient
translation of data
translatability and
speed going from early research through
your clinical development
it's also important to keep in mind that
every stage of critique development and
data collection
are really opportunities to streamline
these assays
whether it's research pre-clinical phase
or manufacturing
it's important to realize each of those
phases can also have
internal groups or external groups
whether that's your
contract manufacturing organization or a
research organization
or a lot of companies also have academic
collaborators that they work with
and while these are uh these are great
places to have data collection but also
potential places for data variability
it's important to keep that in mind as
you go throughout the development
process
and to highlight one specific area of
this drug development process
just cartoon manufacturing is is
multifaceted
in itself and utilizes facts analytics
at multiple stages throughout that
manufacturing process
and if you haven't gotten my point yet
i'm trying to make these flow cytometry
assays that you develop
are used frequently and consistently
from research through development
through clinical and commercial
and it's really important to know
best ways to optimize and you can
utilize these assays
so that your data can be continuing
continuous
and translatable from each phase of
development
all steps of flow cytometry assays can
also be sources of human
error and variability whether it's the
cell labeling process
where you need to keep in mind
lock-a-lot reagent variability
or even pipetting error running samples
on the cytometer where you need to
remember
machine operations can change over time
how you set up that machine
is critical if you have different
machines at different sites or different
groups within a company
you need to keep that in mind and how
they run across machines
and also operator operator variability
and then the final step which is of
course analyzing that data
population gating is something to keep
in mind they can be quite subjective
from group to group depending on how you
gate
uh and one
important question as you look
throughout these steps of flow cytometry
is what ways can we can we identify
these sources of variability early on in
the process
and try to prevent or reduce them
accordingly so i'm kind of i'm going to
dive in
into some key areas that i think that we
can
make significant improvements to these
sources
so that you can ensure data
reproducibility and translatability over
time
with the end goal of hopefully speeding
up your drug development process
for those of you that aren't as familiar
with tar-tea analytics
and in particular these these flow-based
assays for various stages can actually
frequently overlap
so i've listed here on the left some
various
panels or assays that are frequently
done within car t analytics research or
pre-chemical groups
whether it's viability potency phenotype
activation editing for gene edited
products
phosphorylation depending on your
technology and as you
uh as you transition from this research
and pre-clinical phase to a more
clinical
focused development phase
those same assays are actually
uh given a different name
for a clinical or regulatory purpose for
the viability or identity purity
and safety and i think it's important to
realize that and recognize this overlap
early on in the development process so
that you can design panels
that can be used from research through
clinical
before i dive in into five areas that we
can hone and optimize
your flow cytometry based assays i want
to list three points to keep in mind
when you
when you're creating a robust and
sustainable analytics infrastructure
and number one is that humans make
mistakes and that is okay
identify those areas where you think
that there might be
significant sources of human error and
try to improve it as early as possible
number two always have the next
development stage in mind when making
your analytics decisions
whether it's buying hardware designing
panels
or creating sops you want to make sure
that those
are standardized from start to finish to
ensure an optimal transition
and simplicity is key while these
while these products are extremely
complex in nature and our analytics need
to be
equally robust to keep up with these
complex products
the simpler that you can make your
panels
the better or simpler the operation of
those panels
the better
i'm now going to dive into five areas
that i
think you need to focus on when really
streamlining and optimizing the flow
cytometry assays
to ensure the sufficient transluce
transition of assays over time
number one will be the assay and panel
design
number two is the hardware selection and
the design of that hardware
number three is maintaining performance
of your machines over time
or device device synchronization and how
to do that
and five is maintaining operations
between groups and sites which is key
the first area in flow of photography to
keep in mind to streamline and optimize
are these is assay and panel design
considerations and some solutions design
panels with as minimal spectral
spillover as possible
and if you if you need if you need to
have panels that are complex and do have
spill over into other channels you'll of
course need to compensate
and think early within that design of
how you're going to compensate
and if needed make sure that you
standardize
the methodology of that conversation
across groups and sites
and if possible and the hardware allows
it automate that compensation
you want to design these panels or
assays for longevity across phases of
development
so that you don't have to change retune
pause and refocus every time another
group or another stage
needs to take over that assay
think about if your panels are going to
be compatible across multiple
instruments
it's very common for groups or
institutions to have
a particular favorites when it comes to
hardware or software
you really want to make sure that those
panels are going to be compatible
across stages and sites and of course
controls
when possible use commercially available
controls
but if you need to uh create a master
cell bank
and if you need to and if you have
identified that a master cell bank is
needed
start as early as possible so that you
can validate and have the documentation
necessary so that that master cell bank
can be used for multiple stages
on some different solutions for these
considerations as i said if conference
is needed
standardize and automate when possible
um try to select reagents from a single
company as well
you know i can't tell you how many times
i've had panels where
one or two antibodies are from one
company
and then other antibodies are from
another
and if one company has a manufacturing
issue
with one of their antibodies then your
whole panel can't be used
and also ensure this might sound very
rudimentary but
really ensure that your asses and panels
are robust before transferring to
another group
it might work for one particular purpose
but try to
try to really push the limits of those
assays
to make sure that you're going to be
able to troubleshoot things that might
come along in later stages
beyond the optimal conditions for your
product or your process
the second area to optimize your flow
cytometry assays
and processes is really the hardware
selection and design step
so really keep in mind the design of
your instruments that not
not always all cytometers are made the
same way
they might have different optical
components or detection components that
can really
change how your data is acquired or the
ability to run your panels on different
instruments
the display of those fluorescent values
can also change from machine to machine
and not only machine to machine but
software to software
so try to be as consistent as possible
whether
you're an early company able to
standardize the hardware or software
across
groups and manufacturing sites
or if you're a mid-size or larger
company
and you're able to alter what groups are
doing over
time try to be as consistent as possible
keep reproducibility in mind um
whether it's running assays on the same
instrument over time
whether it's running the same assay
across the same model of the instrument
from either group to group or site to
site or
vendor to vendor for those of you that
utilize
external manufacturing organizations
keep reproducibility in mind
and hardware as an import hardware
selection is an important stage
to utilize and optimize uh keeping
reproducibility in mind
solutions if possible use that same
machine at every location that data is
being generated
um and if not at least a line on those
optical and detection components
and for those when you have identified
that there are large differences
in the hardware or software being used
to analyze
your fax analyses or excuse me your fax
data
just have early conversations comparing
those machines or software
as soon as possible
the third area to ensure and optimize
your flow cytometry assays
is to maintain equivalent performance of
your machines over time
so keep in mind what your control method
is going to be
are you going to use master cell banks
are you going to use single stain beads
or rainbow beads then check your those
target mfis have been set and
standardized
and just adjusted accordingly
are you going to use commercial reagents
um another thing to keep in mind might
sound rude and treat but make sure that
you're doing regular maintenance on your
machines
uh it's extremely important to to
utilize those
recommendations to not only do
your daily weekly and monthly
maintenance internal to a site
but also make sure your the vendor of
that machine is coming in to do
a more extended calibration over time
speaking of calibration this is the
first time i will plug in
beam and beam's use of some of miltoni's
reagents and infrastructure is the
ability to use their own calibration
and in combination automated calibration
on their max cloud systems so i have a
picture below showing how easy it is
to be able to take their calibration
beads
whether it's daily or every other day
depending on
what you've decided is is most optimal
for your assays
you scan a barcode run the calibration
and instead of having to adjust
everything manually the system actually
automated
automatically adjusts for you and i
can't tell you for those that have had
to run
um calibrations and flucitometers
manually before
having a machine do it for you is
definitely a breath of fresh air so if
you haven't seen
uh how this is used or some of how you
know chinese instruments
can utilize such automated
calibration mechanics definitely check
check them out on their website
the next area for optimization is really
multi-site harmonization of those
instrument settings and calibration in
your sop calibrations
remember that each of those instruments
have intrinsic differences with
detectors and channels
that can also perform with variability
whether it's the exact same machine that
you have at multiple sites
or different machines they're all going
to have their own variability from
machine one to machine machine two
reagent and staining synchro
synchronization are critical
uh what you know keeping in mind lots of
lot consistency
and also how you're staining your cells
one of the most significant areas that
i've seen over time
of data variability actually comes from
how
the exact same protocol has been run
from group to group for site to site
uh and lastly you know post optimization
of both your ins
your instrument and reagent and phantom
synchronization
and the ability to monitor your data
over time
and be able to either manually or
hopefully automatically or use an
automated system to adapt when possible
some solutions these considerations is
really make sure that you're setting up
sops as soon as possible in your process
um if if you have standardized practices
in place
you're going to it's going to pay
dividends for you down the road
especially for those early research
groups that are transitioning the assays
to later stage development groups
when possible use premixed antibody
cocktails
another place where i'll plug milton's
infrastructure
is in here if you keep
if you uh have been purchasing
antibodies from one company such as
melting over time
they actually provide a service where
they can take your panels that you've
been running
and provide you with a pre-mixed
antibody cocktail
so that either you or your external
manufacturers
don't have to individually add each
antibody to your mix
you take your tree set aliquot out and
you can remove that
potential source of variability from
that stainless step
and as i said using automation automated
solutions when possible and i'll
actually go into that in a bit
of how miltoni has their own solution
to be able to use automated software to
then
calibrate instruments across multiple
sites and now i'll actually talk a
little bit more about some of
miltoni's reagents and software's uh
software components that beam has really
been a fan of from
from day one the first one is actually
the reaffinity antibodies
that that can be used as a solution that
we do
believe improve data and streamline your
workflows
and i i couldn't have made these images
better so i've taken this straight from
miltoni's brochure
they are commonly generated uh with
the key in mind to really have
uh consistency and reproducibility from
locked lot
um noted here that they have the mutated
fc region
um really keeping uh keeping in mind
uh eliminating that background that a
lot of us are very familiar with
when staining our cells um also
they all have one universal igg-1
isotype
for those that had panel design
experience in the past
you can see a great schematic on the
right
highlighting that benefit of only having
one isotype control needed
if you have a panel of say 10 different
antibodies here that
multiple different isotypes is
extremely
extremely useful to only to be able to
transition those to multi-urea system
to be able to only have one isotype
control in all of your panels
uh we also uh stand behind their
advertised uh benefits of of being
superior to hydrodon
hybridoma monoclonals in several key
aspects
whether it's reducing that background
which i mentioned by having them reach
an
fc receptor you can see some of their
own data that's generated here
with a mouse monoclonal run on the left
or one of the rhea antibodies run on the
right
with and without fc block you can see
that
there is no change in that background
signal with the rhea antibodies
but there is a benefit from that fc
block
uh when using a mouse monoclonal because
you did need to block
uh block the background signal from that
superior purity you know
quite common with hybridoma models
hybridoma monoclonal antibody production
to have contaminating
light change in your production and you
can see
mass spec images on the right showing
that contamination
with the red asterisk compared to rhea
antibodies which are recombinantly
generated
so you don't have that issue and also
enhanced specificity
showing the comparison between
monoclonals and that re-antibody from
left to right
another key piece of software that
miltoni has that being
is big fans of is their smart gain
technology which actually allows for
reduced time and effort to harmonize
multiple instruments
whether it's within your lab within
groups or within manufacturing sites
across the world
on the left i've listed traditional
methods that usually have to take to
synchronize multiple instruments
whether it's ident she's starting out
with identifying
your master settings validating those
settings
on your master instrument panel
you off you would then have to optimize
your instrument settings on additional
instruments to deliver
that equipment from instrument to
instrument
um you would then monitor your gains and
performance over time
and really ensure a harmonization
from instrument to instrument insight to
site milton's smart game technology
actually allows you to skip some of
those or have confidence in some of your
final stages and really do this
efficiently
so you you would only need to identify
settings and validate
your panel on one instrument you take
all of those settings that you set up
and validated from one instrument
and take that to any other instrument
with
you know a simple usb load and you can
ensure that that same panel
will run the same way on the same
instrument
with reproducibility and confidence
we've really had great success with this
with multiple instruments on site and
even
tech transfers from site to site we're
big fans of this technology
the last key consideration to keep in
mind when optimizing your flow cytometry
workflows
is managing operations across groups and
sites
so as i've been saying before operator
to operator variability is reality
that's going to happen
whether it's the knowledge transfer or a
tech transfer
from group to group or site to site
whether it's a day-to-day assay setup
calibration compensation and data
analysis
variability is going to happen and you
need to brainstorm ways to minimize that
that variability as much as possible
the final solution really is to also
think about how you can simplify
all of these steps and automate them as
much as possible
the final place where i'll put a plug-in
for miltoni and their
software and infrastructure is their
express modes
where you can actually have a complete
system
to automate your sample run all the way
through analysis
and they even have express modes
tailored for car t cells
in in general where you would start your
run
walk away the express mode would do
everything
in in the analysis
and when you come back your analysis
support is ready to go
um we actually think this would be a
great utility for
uh for processes that you're really
running in high numbers
such as autologous therapies where
you're running the same process
over and over and over again and you
really want to remove that variability
from your analyses
um you know you can go on their site and
check out
i believe they have about 12 different
express modes uh specifically tailored
for car t-cell technologies
if you don't find one that is
good for you or your needs um you can
actually work with them to create custom
express modes
that utilize your own data to generate
an algorithm
to do all of your gating analysis and
report generation
for you in a very efficient streamline
manner
so now that you've kept those five key
considerations to
really optimize uh and streamline your
flow cytometry workflows
what is the final ingredient needed to
reduce the bench to bedside time
uh in my vote i would say it's
communication
communication at every stage as frequent
and early as possible
some key points of discussion to keep in
mind
during these conversations is is asking
yourself
can your early r d panels or assets work
for your later stage needs
so that that would require communication
from early research groups to some of
your later stage analytical teams
and having a discussion about how you
can design those panels
very thoughtfully to not have to re
retool and retune at every stage of the
process
if changes are needed try to come up
with a plan ahead of time
you know really be proactive about
about being able to make changes to
those processes and know how you're
going to
uh how you're going to make those
changes
you know keep in mind when you are
making changes to your panels it's okay
but try to do so in a way that you can
ensure data continuity
whether that's changing some
fluorophores in the panel
or completely changing hardware you want
to try to
make sure that the data you've already
generated in your development process
can be used for later stages if you need
to go back and reference that older data
think about how to communicate issues
issues will come up with your asses over
time
whether you come up with it whether you
have a manufacturing run
it really highlights maybe a potential
design issue
be encouraging of communication of
issues
uh and the last thing to keep in mind is
adapting to new regulatory
requirements uh if you're at a company
that has already submitted things to
regulate your regulatory agency
don't assume that that those same
requirements are going to be
exactly tailored for your your next
product
as we are building these uh complex
therapies and adding more and more
technologies to it
we need to be ready to adapt for those
new regulatory requirements
and to conclude my talk today i'll i'll
leave you with five things to keep in
mind
these car t therapies are really are
going to require appropriate analytics
as these products become
more complex over time so utilize those
five key
considerations that i've listed earlier
to ensure that
your flow cytometry data can be
optimized as early as possible
and streamline from early research
through clinical development
think early about how to build this
infrastructure of
reagents hardware and software that can
be maintained throughout each stage
whether that's one one brand one company
etc as i said earlier
early and frequent communication from
these early research groups
all the way through clinton development
will be crucial to efficiently transfer
those assays ensure data or robustness
and approach regulatory agencies as soon
as possible
to make sure what you're developing at
those early research or pre-clinical
stages
really meets the needs of your product
and development
and now i'd be happy to take any
questions from the audience
thank you aaron for your informative
presentation
we'll now start the live q a portion of
the webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far
left of your screen we'll answer as many
of your questions as we have time for
let's get started our first question is
how do you implement standardized
analytical readouts across the car t
manufacturing workflow
that's a great question i think this
really requires a conversation from
every
group that's involved in the development
workflow
so if you're in an early research group
you know bring in
your analytical teams to see if there's
a way to choose one brand
or company or infrastructure that works
for you in later stage development needs
if you know that you are if you know
that you're also going to be seeking
external manufacturing organizations to
to manufacture your product you know
have conversations early with them as
well to see what hardware and software
they have on site
and if it's and if possible if there's
uh
if there's room in the budget to be able
to synchronize
across sites i think that is always
great to keep in mind
okay great thank you aaron our next
question
if there are changes needed later on in
an
established sop how would you go about
exacting those changes and why is it
easier to make adjustments earlier on
compared to later
that's also a great question i
i would say uh you know as i said
earlier in the talk you
you need to expect this to happen it's
you're going to make changes and
establish sops
and hopefully you have a plan about how
you make those changes
um so you know we we have done this on
uh
recently as well where you we've ident
we've identified an area where we need
to make a change in a
specific protocol um and again it's it's
communication it's that final ingredient
you really need to make sure
you're doing things efficiently but also
that you're able to pivot efficiently
so identify the change that you need to
make
bring all the groups together where that
change will be uh
impacting them um also see if that
change is going to impact any of your
previous data
so if you're changing a panel et cetera
um you know
pilot that change and see if you can get
the same data
that you've already generated in the
past or if the change was required to
improve your data
um really confirm that that change
is necessary to the second part of the
question
um you know i think it is it's much
easier to make changes early compared to
later
due to some of the uh
kind of manufacturing and regulatory uh
requirements of later stage development
so when early earlier research groups
tend to have a lot of ability to pivot
and change say panels et cetera but as
you
as you uh solidify and lock these sops
in place
it's extremely challenging to start
generating
really expensive manufacturing run data
make changes and be able to use those
previous
runs or say regulatory filings
or important decisions that are going to
have an impact on your product
development long term
so i think that if if you remember
anything from this answer
identify the need
to make changes as fast as possible and
try to do it early on
so that you don't have to
you don't have to make significant
changes later on in the process that
might be very costly for you and your
company
okay great our next question when
dealing with multi-center sites
how does about ensuring efficient
and efficient tech transfer and what are
some hurdles
potentially prepare for
that's a great question ensuring
efficient tech transfers
number one is to have a solidified and
robust
sop in place you know look at your sop
make sure it's as detailed as possible
so that when you're
communicating or showing another site
how to do
either staining or running there are no
questions that could be asked
that aren't listed um
be clear and communicative you know
traditionally people have been able to
travel
from site to site to perform a tech
transfer
and these days especially in in the time
that's coded
it's not always possible to make that to
make that trip
something that beam is actually used um
recently is the our webcams
where we've actually recorded uh one
one site doing a certain essay and the
other site doing the same essay
so that we can be a little bit flexible
given some of the safety requirements
these days
um some hurdles to to potentially
prepare for
even though you might think you have uh
every detail possible listed in your sop
something will come up where uh an
operator
at one site has been performing an essay
one way
and another uh was performing it
slightly different
that might have been skewing your data
that's okay be ready for it
and just make sure that it's
communicated in the next version every
sop
another place for all i'll plug in your
opinion their technologies
is being able to pick systems that have
things like uh no penny smart game
technology
is has actually been a lifesaver for for
veeam
in a lot of ways where we can have all
of our instrument settings done
at our master site in
the settings another site and really
have
confidence that the data on one machine
was being run
uh excuse me ensure confidence that the
data on one machine
will be uh the same data on another site
we've had really successful uh tech
transfers using simultaneous machines
recently and we're very thankful for
that
um another hurdle to prepare for
is being able to just make changes to
your sops
you know not only are you going to find
that you didn't have details listed
that's causing some operator to operate
or variability but you'll need to make
changes
and depending on the site and their
ability and flexibility to make changes
it can it can be more or less effort but
be prepared for that
try to be flexible and be as
communicative
as possible
okay great i have another question here
in addition to having instrument
redundancy to address consistency
are there supplemental tools or
protocols that can ensure instrument and
data harmonization
if so would those tools be different in
a research
versus industrial space
that's that's a great question you know
i don't think every
uh i don't think every
uh institution you know of course has
the ability to have
instrument redundancy i mean for those
that uh you aren't familiar
you know if if one instrument shuts down
you have the ability to use another
instrument
i think that
the only way if you don't have the
ability to have multiple instruments on
site
is to make sure that you're maintaining
the one you have to the best of your
abilities
um you know you get there are best
practices listed
on every manufacturer um that really
uh will allow you to make sure that your
machines are running
efficiently and smoothly over time
because all of us in the flow cytometry
space know
how much of a pain it is when you have a
laser that isn't aligned
properly and you have to have a
technician come on site that really
to fix your machine which can really
hinder your ability to acquire a lot of
your data
i think it does you know going to the
second part of the question
um the tools can be a little bit
different for the research versus
industrial space
but they don't have to be you know i
think the
one of the reasons that we've been big
fans miltoni
is is uh being able to have that same
instrument from
you know early research groups uh
throughout later
later research and development groups um
you know one of the one of the cool
things about their tech is that they
have
live support where instead of needing to
schedule
and shut down a machine for multiple
days
it's possible to have live support with
them to be able to fix your machine
right there and then on the spot by by
syncing into your device um
you know i think the the biggest
differences that you might see between
that research and industrial space
is potentially the ability to have um
two instruments but i don't see why some
of those tools or protocols need to be
need to be that different
okay thank you aaron we have time for
one more question
what are the hallmarks of variable data
and how does a company
address this what are the consequences
of unreliable data in the rt
manufacturing space
yes for flow cytometry
i think one of the biggest spaces for
your where you'll
see your data be variable um can be
you know mfi of a target you know when
you get
really comfortable with different
protocols uh
a lot of it a lot of that variability
might come
uh visually where people that have run
panels over and over and over again
might see something shift
um especially in one of your controls
if you say have a master cell bank that
you've been running
you really make sure that those controls
or however you're harmonizing or
synchronizing your performance to the
machine
make sure that those controls are
running the same way over time
you know i think the uh
it's also possible that one of your
lasers says shift has shifted slowly
over time which is going to happen
and i think to the trained eye you can
see visually
there are also ways to do that
quantitatively um depending on how
your institution is set up some of those
uh some of those
qc parameters so have a discussion
um have a discussion with your group
early on
about how you want to address this
because you might have different
procedures in place but definitely be
prepared for it
some of the consequences for some
unreliable data
if you've you know as i was saying
earlier if you've
gone through multiple extremely
expensive
manufacturing runs and then realized
that one of your panels actually
uh is displaying data that isn't
actually the nature you thought it was
depending on where in that manufacturing
process you are it can
be extremely challenging uh if you're
planning to use
one of your runs say for regulatory
filing um
you know it's it's uh it's not the end
of the world
but um uh it is possible that you might
have to either
uh redo the entire run or
hopefully um hopefully uh
best case scenario when this does happen
is that you
can take retains from from that run
and utilize a new panel to be able to re
re-reacquire those analytics on that on
that manufacturing run
great thank you again aaron and thank
you for your time today
and for your important research we would
also like to thank lab roots and our
sponsor miltonia biotech for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information
you provided at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand
lab roots will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time goodbye